it it really is a terrible idea
to try to change the meaning so that
people can't even get certain thoughts
across so if you ask is it possible for
a white powerless unemployed
working-class person in a poor southern
in order Appalachian town to be have
derogatory opinions about
african-americans and you say oh no we
can't ask if he's racist because racist
means power hi professor it's a pleasure
to meet you nice to meet you I'm Kurt
I'm uncle the director this is Peter and
he's helping me tag-team this interview
okay very good
pleasure to meet you nice to meet you
okay so is it all ready if we just get
right into the questions let's go
starting off I want to know what is the
left we have to define the left and I
would like you to give its defining
traits its characteristics it's hard to
give a definition because political
ideologies turn into tribes and so
people affiliate with those in the group
they like to interact with that they
valued morally and nowadays especially
the United States it's harder and harder
to discern a common intellectual thread
behind the left and the right we see
that especially in the rough it's where
you have pro-russian anti-free trade
right-wingers all go in the mind of
anyone who was a right-wing or even 10
years ago also vote the left has
switched in a number of its affiliations
but I would use it informally in a way
that people tend to identify those who
are sympathetic with with socialism
those who tend to be at least in
American politics more likely to be the
Democratic Party than the Republican
Party there are a number of positions
that go with it but they can often be
blurred as the coalition's themselves
Ricola less would you identify with or
do you identify with someone who's on
the Left no I certainly don't identify
with the right and most people would
identify me based on my positions as
center left in terms of them I believe
in a graduated income tax I believe in
regulations on environmental
despoliation I agree I'm in favor of
from social programs like welfare and
medicine on the other hand I also
believe in the importance of markets I
believe in the primacy of free speech
and individual rights I believe that
policing is an important component of
reduction of violence which is not a
popular view on the left so I have an
eclectic mix which I examine on an
issue-by-issue basis and evaluate in
terms of my best reading of the evidence
but I try not to fall into an ideology
or quite
left there seems to be a considerable
overlap recognizing these differences in
your opinion when does the left go to
far you know let's say a number of ways
is especially the contemporary left has
tended to gravitate toward identity
politics toward seeing debate and
analysis of social issues in terms of
the relative power of different ethnic
groups and races and seeing social
progress in terms of rectifying and
imbalance between whites and blacks or
men and women as opposed to recognizing
discrimination that has occurred but
striving toward a society in which
people are evaluated based on their
individual rights and their individual
merits so identity politics and with
that a a relativistic epistemology that
says that your opinions are determined
to by your race your gender your sexual
orientation your handicap status as
opposed to their internal consistency
and support by evidence
I think there's far too much hostility
to markets into capitalism on the left
is given the historical and contemporary
rector of which societies one we want to
Riven North Korea versus South Korea
West Germany versus East Germany
Venezuela vs. Uruguay for example let's
see though well those are old I think
the as I mentioned before the hostility
on the left to rule of law and law
enforcement is inconsistent with their
role of policing in reducing violent
crime that be another issue that the
left I think has lost touch with with
facts and the importance of market
economies in elevating societies from
extreme poverty the fact that global
extreme poverty has declined by 75
percent in the last 30 years largely
because of liberalisation
market economies in countries like China
and Vietnam and India so those are a
number of issues in which the left has
gone off the tracks
but the contemporary American right is
far worse the Trump is right in
integrating international agreements and
norms which are increasingly going to be
necessary to confront global challenges
like climate change the hostility to any
form of regulation even ones that would
be justified by a market friendly
mindset such as pricing harm to the
environment which even if you're a
staunch capitalist utilize the market
itself will not take care of the
indifference to the the plight of people
who can't contribute enough to a market
economy to support a decent way of life
the difference today to the poor to the
sick after the elderly and therefore a
rather ideological opposition to all
forms of government assistance to the to
the needy we just know again there's
nothing that dictates that you have to
be hostile to social programs if you're
sympathetic to markets because it's just
a basic of
analysis of markets that they don't
provide for for the poor so unless you
just are happy to let the cooler starve
and die of disease you have to have
markets you have to have mechanisms that
the market doesn't provide it is hardly
radical eating if you are a free market
libertarian sorry you've done some work
with the heterodox Academy right I guess
that's right I gave the keynote at their
last meeting for example have you seen
the rise of the campus left do you see
it as becoming more extreme in the past
few years and and can you give some
examples of that if you do see it as
becoming more extreme yeah I think it I
think it has although as I said in my
address contra contra Billy Joel we did
start the fire we did the baby boomers
and there were episodes of intolerance
and shutting down of free speech when I
was an undergraduate number of decades
ago I think there is an increase in the
number of speakers who are decided who
are shouting down with loud protests
sometimes physical alteration
altercations with the setting of fire
alarms and we also know just by
surveys of a political affiliation of
professors that they are drifting rather
sharply to the left
in many humanities departments there are
more Marxists than there are people who
identify as conservatives why do you
think that is some of it is because of
an increase in social and residential
segregation that people with higher
amounts of education will live with
other people who are just like them and
people particularly in on college
campuses or in large cities and people
who are more conservative
tend to be more in the suburbs exurbs in
rural areas partly because academia has
some I think some pathologies in terms
of people hiring people like themselves
so that once there was a generation that
got tenure in many departments they
replicated themselves hired people with
the same so those are a couple of the
reasons is there's also a natural
there's a I think a natural affinity
among intellectuals for more liberal
positions some of the justified it was
often liberals and leftists who are at
the forefront of social movements that
universally now I take for granted and
that we now enjoy such as racial
equality gender equality and gay rights
so some degree of liberal filters may be
a good thing but when it comes to
stifling disagreement
recognising that universities are not
structured in a totalitarian fashion and
that there still are orthodoxies in
universities and taboos some of which
you have touched on do you believe that
universities follow a propaganda model
or would you not go that far no I mean I
think there are tendencies in some
disciplines in some departments toward
replicating with particular ideologies
the other hand a lot of members of the
heterodox Academy are university
professors a lot of the responses to
campus suppression come from campuses so
it is not it is not utilitarian it is
not a propaganda Factory you had
mentioned a variance by discipline in
terms of how ideological these
disciplines become that there's a
variance what explains this variance why
are certain disciplines more ideological
let's say than others this is purely
speculative but I think disciplines that
are closer to the sciences tend to be a
little less ideological because there is
at least a commitment and sometimes the
reality of holding your beliefs to a
caracal account to see which of your
beliefs survive empirical tests whereas
in disciplines where that is not on a
norm or an ideal or an aspiration they
can be more justyou force of personality
charisma rhetoric that can preserve
certain beliefs against a possible
falsification I remember you were
talking about the effects of political
correctness in the form of a backlash a
rise of the right like a counter
position and you already mentioned that
the right seems to pose a greater threat
right now can you talk about the
relationship why is it that why is it is
it necessary that when the left gets too
out of hand and the right does something
similar that's not exactly the argument
it's more that when opinions get
suppressed
and people who might even be reasonable
same opinion suppress suspect that the
academia or whatever form it is can't
handle the truth that bear if they can't
show why a position is wrong why it
seemed coherent why is contradicted by
the facts but they just fed it out
completely
they suspect well there must be
something to that idea because if
there's something wrong with it they
could just show it's what was wrong we
wouldn't have to squelch it and so they
can retreat to their own bubbles we're
much more extreme and dogmatic and
categorical and unsubtle versions of the
hypothesis can that I can confess her
unopposed by people who might be more
conversant with it with the data and the
counter arguments so they can be a kind
of maligned mirror image of campus
orthodoxy in both write orthodoxy now by
the way the reason that I think that the
right is worse is because they they have
power I mean their senators they're the
governor's they're the President and
though the right-wing orthodoxy is much
more dangerous than professors and
students shutting out speakers in
universities but they do they can feed
each other where a lot of the so let me
just be concrete there are universities
there is often a hostility and a lack of
comprehension of market economies now in
reality there is no such thing as a
market economy that does not have
regulation and social transfers
redistribution that's just the
libertarian fantasy of a perfect
anarcho-capitalist free market country
where the government does nothing but
enforce contracts and prevent the use of
force does not exist and good reasons
why it doesn't exist there are number of
reasons why it's not level but um
because often those on
I campus assume that capitalism and free
markets equate to anarcho-capitalism and
capitalism is pretty much a dirty word
on campus then get a hard-line
libertarian rebound we're in a lot of
the American right there's hostility to
all regulation of hostility to all
redistribution often resulting in the
gutting of completely justifiable
mechanisms of regulation or or social
programs a reaction to the uncritical
hostility to capitalism on the campus
left so any it's unhealthy when you have
such a lack of nuance a lack of
compromise a lack of discussion and you
get polarized extremes and we're seeing
that in politics or the one hand
universities on the other let's get into
some cognitive science I remember you
were suggesting that we have some leeway
or some elasticity in our brain for what
we categorized as an in-group versus an
out-group obviously because none of us
were around each other a million years
ago or ten thousand years ago but that
this but the identity politics somehow
undermines that or or takes advantage of
it in a negative manner can you explain
this one of the core beliefs of the of
the earth right of the ban in Breitbart
Trump version of modern nationalism is
that we are hard-wired to fall into
tribes that the idea of a global
civilization of transnational
organizations is utopian is futile
because we evolved as tribal creatures
now I think we do have tribal instincts
but what counts as a tribe is highly
elastic and certainly not a race because
in our evolutionary ancestry would
seldom have encountered a person driven
off the race link so you couldn't have a
built-in hostility other races only as
time
more to some notion of coalition or clan
people who are on a side who might have
some fictive relatedness that that makes
them seem like one brothers or or or
like families but that the idea that
this coincides with a modern
nation-state with the United States of
America or France is I think
anachronistic we have multiple tribal
affiliations were loyal to our
University to our sports team to our
state or province to our country and
that there it's not that we categorize
ourselves as belonging to one and only
one tribe equals nation which is in
locked in zero-sum competition with
other nations and that is the basis of
crumb pused foreign policy
okay for our viewers for the people
watching this can you define the
enlightenment broadly speaking what are
the values of the Enlightenment well the
there's no official definition because
it didn't they weren't like opening
closing ceremonies there's no membership
card so there really is no definition
it's it's a term that's loosely applied
to as a movement to a number of thinkers
in the sec typically in the second half
or second two-thirds of the 18th century
primarily in England Scotland America
and Germany it tends to include a
embrace of science skepticism toward
religion and scripture an emphasis on
the power of reason and of human rights
when I referred to enlightenment ideals
I spell it out in the subtitle of my
book I mean the reason science humanism
and progress now I don't claim that that
is the correct definition of the
arrangement I don't care what the
correct definition is there isn't one I
wrote a defense of Reason science
humanism and progress I used
enlightenment as a loose label form I
could have also called it secular
humanism we're gonna call it cosmic
power liberalism enlightenment ideals
were attached here but nothing is at
stake over whether the term is correct
in that case let us dive into some of
these ideas particularly progress and
humanism to start I think it's fair to
say that the term progress is very long
and diverse history history philosophy
in the interest of synchronizing our
metric we'd like to touch on the
similarities and differences of your
view of progress and its previous
historical usage for example the
philosopher of progress Hegel believed
that material substance conformed to a
sort of set inevitable ideological track
and that this was how history were
a sort of unfolding of material on a set
course of ideas and that this was
inevitable but this seems to conflict
with your view of progress would you
agree absolutely yeah well when I think
of progress it's not that but it is
honest but where does your view of
progress differ first of all I deny that
there exists a force dynamic dialectic
that we can call progress the human
condition does not have progress built
then quite the contrary
the University is a different trust kind
of grinds us down both three forces of
of entropy the growth of natural growth
disorder and the process of evolution
which is a competitive process where
various germs and parasites and
pathogens and pestilence organisms and
spoilage organisms are always trying to
do us in either way in our well-being
and the only way to progress happens in
the teeth of all of these forces pushing
against it is the extent to which humans
use ingenuity that is their
understanding of how the world works and
they deploy it in the service of
improving human wellbeing where human
well-being would include health
happiness prosperity freedom stimulation
the social ties are the kind of things
that the people like and want to the
extent that the kind of things that
people like and want improve over the
course of time that's progress and what
makes it possible is humans solving
problems deploying their understanding
of the world to make other humans better
off thank you we're just trying to make
sure that our viewers understand how
your view of Progress differs from let's
say the traditional if there is one view
of progress and to the rest absolutely
it's extremely important because people
often confuse them and indeed the notion
that I have a problem is actually rather
simple and boring one namely if people
live longer
that's progress people are less likely
to be murdered that's progress
if women can do what they want to do
that's progress so the Enlightenment
thinkers in the early enlightenment high
technological progress to ideological
progress arguing that the two go
hand-in-hand would you also agree to
that assumption not necessarily because
it depends on what the technologies are
deployed to do nuclear weapons for
example our technological tour de force
but not a example of progress because
they're designed to kill people who said
they'd be better off antibiotics on the
other hand oxidation panty retroviral
those are examples of progress because
they also involve human ingenuity but in
order to make people happier and
healthier in longer lived so the
progress technology only drives progress
when it's deployed in the service of
humanism and that's why crucially in my
subtitle I had humanism
as one of the ideals without it
scientific advances don't necessarily
lead to progress
thank you we find with the russian
philosopher Alexander Dugan he believes
that these two should also not be
equated that technological progress an
ideological progress can be leagues
apart when looking at the West do you
find that this is the case or do you
find that when you look at Western
societies that their technological
progress does match their ideological
progress
sorry about that I don't know if you're
gonna do this so that's going online
unedited okay so it'll be yeah sometimes
not always and it's important to
distinguish enlightenment ideals with
Western ideals of the Enlightenment a
lot of the ideals originated in the West
all ideas have to originate somewhere
but they're they're not the same thing
and in the West there's been furious
opposition to enlightenment ideals I
encounter enlightenment in romantic
militarism in romantic nationalism so
Western and enlightenment are definitely
not the same thing and within the West
there there have been many examples of
progress often driven by by science and
technology or by philosophy and human
rights the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights it's hard to even to call
that Western it did most of it was
written by by some Western thinkers and
it was pushed by Eleanor Roosevelt but
with the opposition of many forces
within the West the United States is
very squeamish
for example her signing the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights because
there was Jim Crow those racial
segregation
Britain was uneasy about the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights but they
still had their colonies where as a
number of Eastern countries were happy
to sign on Ethiopia and Africa a number
of Muslim majority countries were happy
to so later on so is universal human
rights a Western concept well somewhat
and somewhat not understand
that it varies and the way it's
benefiting like an ideas have been
adopted would you still say that the
genesis of the Enlightenment is a
uniquely European phenomenon no some of
the parallel ideas originated in other
parts of the world in in India in
Ethiopia there was a hermit living in a
cave in Ethiopia named Yakov who
originally sorry independently came up
with a number of the like things like
skepticism of a scripture and human
rights more recently in the family of
ideas that I think most of us would want
to promote their ideas that distinctly
came from the East such as Gandhi's
concept of nonviolent resistance such as
restorative justice and Ubuntu from
South Africa so the family of ideas that
center around using knowledge to advance
human well-being they can come from
anywhere if we dilute the Enlightenment
down to just sort of these Universal
ideas as opposed to a specific European
movement do we run the risk of sort of
decaffeinated it into just the kind of
core essence of human beings that seeks
freedom oh it's still the Enlightenment
well yes and no so no in terms of
capital e enlightenment if find that you
want to use the word to refer to these
family of ideas that originated in
certain fingers the second half of the
18th century but words often often have
multiple meanings there are far fewer
words in the English language than there
are concepts and so we can distinguish
the Enlightenment referring to a
historical period and movement from
enlightenment ideals namely reason
science and humanism and as long as
we'll clear which the work we're
referring to on the news Gordon light
would you attribute the polygenesis of
these Enlightenment ideas as a
reflection of our human nature that
human beings want freedom seek
rationality universally and this is why
it's polygenesis some extent they think
is that we all want freedom for
ourselves the idea that we ought to
promote freedom for everyone may not be
so hardwired into human nature but it
might be universal nonetheless with a
combination of features of human
rationality and self-interest just the
logical necessity that you can't
coherence waiting saying but only my
rights count because I mean you're not
well project doesn't recognize me but
versus you and so when you have certain
human intuitions such as our own desire
for health and happiness for ourselves
and our families but then sharpened in
the core or hardened in the crucible of
debate in discussion with people who are
unlike us then the requirement of
logical consistency paired with the
desire for freedom and well-being will
push in the direction of universal I can
namely soon as I'm in conversation with
you I can't say well only my happiness
counts because I mean you're not and
hope for you to continue the
conversation if we're gonna come to any
kind of agreement it's gonna have to be
well if I value my freedom I've got to
acknowledge your desire for your freedom
so let's come up with a social
arrangement that gives us the maximum
amount of freedom consistent with our
not impinge upon each other's freedom we
come up with a social contract there's
not exactly human nature that a single
person thinking up how the world would
work would never come up with that or
probably wouldn't but with human nature
in the combination of discourse debate
holding other people to account
ferreting out law school inconsistencies
can I think will push in the direction
of humanism than other Enlightenment
values
if if these sort of intuitions that are
that are required for this crucible of
debate discussion are universal and are
something that human beings didn't
choose to have they sort of transcend
our conscious choice and are ascribed
into our natures is it something that's
therefore beyond humanism in the sense
that human beings control being the
instincts that cause them to be
enlightened they are because if maybe
evolution larger historical factors and
that we just kind of play along in this
role I think they're they're natural in
the sense that as people start to
interact with larger and larger
universes of discourse
more people who are unlike themselves
and and as they learn from historical
mistakes as they see what works and what
doesn't anybody of course it pushes them
in the direction of universal a few
minutes but if although it's far from
determined because ideals and norms and
institutions like checks and balances
liberal democracy peer-review scientific
communities free speech those are not an
inevitable they're not even particularly
natural they are optimal in the sense
that if we seek to improve our condition
those are the mechanisms that will allow
us to do it
and I think it's for that reason that
you do see some you do see progress
materially there is it seems to be a
historical movement toward abolishing
slavery even sacrifice discriminatory
laws and practices and cruel practices
not even not inevitable not monotonic
but unmistakable and I think it's the
combination of me of human interests and
the inherent impartiality or objectivity
of a reason women where did you apply it
if as soon as you get commit to reason
you're forced along certain tracks
if the let's say this is a sort of game
theory scenario right where like you
said my recognizing if your rights and
your recognizing my rights lead to an
optimal sort of super ordinance
situation arthel are the rules that make
that super ordinate situation are
optimal game we should be playing
determined by human beings or are human
beings players in the game where the
rules
those rules are beyond us and if they
are beyond us
is it still fair to say that human
beings are the greatest
determiners of their of their destiny
that there's still humanism or at least
for these rules transhuman yeah yeah I
tend to think there are trans human is
that any rational rational
self-interested species would be forced
to them in the inner limit as discourse
proceeds over time they are thought up
by humans they in constraint unit so for
example I love the idea of peer review
in science and I hate the experience of
getting reviews of my own manuscripts
back because like all scientists I think
idiots would miss the point why do you
want me to mess up my beautiful paper on
the other hand stepping back I realize
as much as I hate the reviews that I get
at a meta level I sign on to the whole
idea of peer review knowing and
simultaneously that I'm right about
everything that I say and that as a
human being if it couldn't possibly be
right about everything that I say so we
do have to live with that dual conscious
consciousness as the combination
probably of our evolutionarily fake
human nature which is to believe that
we're always right and Noble and the
conclusion that were forced to in
discussion with others in
acknowledgement of history that yeah
everyone thinks they're right it can't
all be right they are wrong I'm not a
Superman I'm not a deity I can't be any
less fallible that everyone else that I
see therefore I'm going to submit to
those rules so don't come naturally but
in something that we can fall into given
debate given experience given awareness
of history
Fukuyama wrote about the end of history
which is essentially claiming that
liberalism is the undisputed champion of
the world
but then there's Alexander Alexander
Dugan who says no there's a multiplicity
of other options viable options do you
see there being another option to
enlightenment to enlightenment values
there's no viable alternative to reason
certainly if as soon as you start to
argue that there might be we've lost the
argument because you've appealed to
reason or if you conversely if you
reject reason there's no reason for
anyone to take the argument seriously
because you confess there's no good
reason to believe it so I don't think
there's an alternative to reason I don't
think it's an alternative to humanism
other than that you could argue for I
mean you could impose it by brute force
and again you're not about argument then
it is I have a little justifiable for
the same reason I don't think there's an
alternative to science now this isn't is
these our normative arguments is what we
ought to strive for if you interpret
Fukuyama's making historical argument
that societies will inevitably go in
that direction it's not clear that he
himself would have argued that but that
certainly isn't true he could certainly
have our society's evolving into a
dictatorship and other forms of
authoritarianism in terms of the
direction that the world has taken I
think it's easy to blow off Fukuyama and
he did set himself up for easy
refutation honking articles that
announced the return of history with the
rise of authoritarian capitalism in
China or nationalist populism in Russia
in the United States on the other hand
in Fukuyama's defense the number of
democracies has increased since he
published that article in 1989 and not
just in the Eastern Europe but in Latin
America in East Asia in Africa and even
with the a clashes it's not clear
in the future how many countries are
gonna model one sells on there's a good
news Russia it seems unlikely so end of
history is a gimmick a minute even
Fukuyama probably didn't really the end
he certainly didn't be history in terms
of stuff no longer happening I mean it
conflict over major systems of national
organization but it's in terms of
whether say France is going to become
more like China in 50 years or China is
going to become more like more like
France it's it's not if I had to bet on
one or the other I'd say try to become
more like France
okay speaking on this is odd divide have
you read Sam Harris as moral landscape
and if so what do you think about it
yeah I am I came to be sympathetic with
with Harris learned in moral landscape I
it is a statement of humanism he made in
some aspects of it more strongly I would
he claims that in a nutshell told was
simplified it that what is moral is a an
empirical matter matter of what makes
people best off and if you interpret
that as saying that it is just an
empirical matter that there is no
philosophical ground into it then I
think that would go too far it's not
clear whether Sam himself would insist
on that
it's a view of progress compatible with
post-modernism
a sort of anti grand narrative ideology
depends on what aspect of post-modernism
here you referred you
you
there may be within most models the idea
that when power imbalances get rectified
when people of color and women wrest
power from white males that would be a
kind of progress but certainly the
notion that there's been a long history
of progress which could continue driven
by science and universal human rights I
think probably most public post
modernists women said wouldn't sign on
to that yeah I'm not sure I would call
that a grand narrative you know if
people if people try to solve problems
occasionally they succeed if they
solutions cumulate and then now life can
get better for more and more people is
that a grand narrative it doesn't sound
so grand to me but it is something that
I would defend okay while we're
irritating the post modernists there's
progressive nations then that means that
there's non progressive nations or even
perhaps backwards nations does this mean
that some cultures are better than
others well better than others in some
ways so I think for example a culture
which wouldn't have equality is better
in that regard in which the girls are
kicked out of school and women are
forced to marry and prevented from
driving and coding so yeah I think it's
a society that executes homosexual
sexuals is morally inferior to one that
has equal rights so yeah I think if you
it sounds more radical than it is but if
you have any world standards whatsoever
societies differ in the degree to which
they implement and enlist in those
regards those practices of those
societies are our superior doesn't mean
that the people are superior doesn't
mean that that any individual has more
inherent moral value than any other one
but in terms of cultures practices
habits yeah how could you maintain the
oxygen any commitments to raise morale
okay I know you gotta go so Peters gonna
ask one question then if I have time
I'll just ask one more okay what is the
cause of this progress that you've
observed in your writings at what
expense
we obtained it when one looks at the
history it's tempting to say that
because of colonialism slavery child
labor in factories that this was sort of
the price cream enlightened societies
paid for their advancement what would
you say to that claim found labor is
certainly astley predates the
Enlightenment that was just the default
you set your children to work in the
farm on the farm I made very briefly to
specify when we mentioned child labor
specifically in the English textile
industry from which the industrial
revolutions are those let's say sparked
there was a recruitment for orphans
small children with nimble fingers that
could work threading machines these are
the specific child laborers referring to
yeah yeah there were well there were a
clearly a number of harms that coincide
it with say with the Industrial
Revolution and if we could go back in
time and make arguments then that we
appreciate now then one can imagine
alternative history that would have had
the advantages of industrialization
without the video harms certainly
colonial exploitation we entity had
educated with beginning with conversant
Cortez and Bizzaro that was way before
the Enlightenment in fact it's kind of
what empires did throughout history as
they conquered and Exploited this their
subjugated crow population so I would
not say that those are certainly a
necessary accompaniment of enlightenment
values but more generally nothing is
occurs with only benefits especially in
hindsight there's a lot that are to have
unfolded differently in terms of the
necessary price that was paid certainly
firm to the environment was an
accompaniment in industrialization that
we still have not dealt with in the case
of greenhouse gas emissions
the next stage anything we didn't want
to call progress is to enjoy the
advances that energy capture has brought
while rectifying and undoing the harm
that we've done to the planet if I may
just press on your answer to a degree
understanding that these let's say
perils and evils predate the
Enlightenment is it still possible that
they were a huge contributing factor for
the success of enlightened societies who
made let's say the most efficient use of
these perils did to some extent so for
example the growth in economies in the
19th century or especially the first
half of the 19th century are we
exploited slave labor particularly in
the United States although of course it
was the 19th century in which slavery
was for the first time in history
abolished in country after country but
yes it is a more general answer is that
as history unfolded there were harms
that accompanied the benefits were they
necessary I don't think so but since
history only unfolded once we'll never
know for sure
that is if enlightenment were applied
more consistently and the rights and
interests of people in populations
populations in Africa and Asia were
taken into account if the universal
human rights movie was Universal
couldn't have had an industrial
revolution and expansion of rights that
truly was universal I think that that
could have happened it didn't happen the
extent that they should have the
universal human rights have to wait at
least a century maybe hundred fifty
years and that is going to history of
Kovach yes okay the last question you
can choose between one of these two do
you feel like some of the new atheist
feel that Jordan Peterson is causing
harm to the Enlightenment project by
making religion more palatable so that's
question number one you can choose that
or what are your thoughts on Noam
Chomsky I know he has some disagreements
with you and I wanted to know if if
you've read them and if you could
outline to our audience what they are
and then yours
sponsors to that you can choose those
two Oh Jordan Peterson is a poly by his
own mission many ways to count for
enlightenment think so including his
sympathy to religion his skepticism
about progress so yes I don't I don't
think I would identify him despite his
intellectual independence he was willing
mr. challenged Authority he is not what
you would call a defender of the project
in terms of Chomsky he I think he has a
being an anarchist himself necessary not
only has a romantic vision of life in
the state of nature about before the
onset of government and civilization the
data pretty much universally show that
there were higher rates of violence in
pre state societies than in state
societies this would include the biggest
analysis does are after I finish better
angels of our nature by a Hosea Jose
Maria Gomez and his collaborators where
they accumulated every datum that they
could come across on race of violence in
ants tribes chiefdoms and States and in
of course there are hundreds of society
they show unequivocally that rates of
violence are lower in state societies
than in tribal societies so I can think
that although no tends to deny that it
goes against his gift i sensibilities
but that's that's what we do suggest if
you look at their entire instead of
cherry picking a few peaceful societies
was an ugly list and and and I am
celebrating the fact that societies have
become more peaceful over time but they
did not start out peaceful thank you so
much time I appreciate it I was a
pleasure thank you so much for your time
and you and sorry for the interruptions
thanks thank you very much have a great
day
yes can you hear me thank you
where are you by the way congratulations
thank you what but the next question is
wearing taupe but what recall okay I'm
going to be in Toronto in a couple of
weeks okay okay okay as a linguist what
do you make of the redefinition of words
primarily at least as far as my research
is shown by the campus left by the
grievous studies or the radical eft or
whatever they're called such as racism
which is the old definition of racism
plus power or violence which is which
now incorporates speech about physical
violence or what constitutes a Nazi
because they may say well words change
all the time we're just changing where
is this which is par for the course so I
want to know what you think about that
words change all the time but it's an
organic bottom-up viral process it's not
something that an interest group can
engineer first of all because you've got
to get buy-in from several hundred
million English speakers and less you're
a a language totalitarian despot you
can't order people how to how to speak
something is catch on and in processes
that don't quite understands and
certainly if it's in the service of an
agenda then there's going to be a lot of
obvious resistance you know if I'm
coca-cola and I say well I'm legislating
from now on the word water will be
coca-cola so every time you want a water
at a restaurant we're gonna serve you
coca-cola billion for it and you say
wait I said that's not what water means
and I say well look words change all the
time you say no wait a second that just
sheer manipulation that's not gonna work
it and should not work and I'd say the
same thing for an interest group trying
to redefine words as people ordinarily
understand them which is the but in any
case the only way in which language
changes any way I can speak with some
Authority here being the chair of the
usage panel of the American Heritage
Dictionary and when I ask my colleagues
of the dictionary how do you guys decide
what the
official meeting Awards is and they say
well we pay attention to the way people
use language so it's not as if any
authority even a dictionary board can
legislate language and in the case of
woods like like racism it it really is a
terrible idea to try to change the
meaning so that people can't even get
certain thoughts across so if you ask is
it possible for a a white powerless
unemployed working-class person in a
poor southern in order Appalachian town
to be have derogatory opinions about
african-americans and you say oh no we
can't ask if he's racist because racist
means that you have to have power well
you can that's the question and
similarly to say that it is impossible
for an African American to have
beginning thoughts about Asians or
whites or for Asians to have bigoted
thoughts about African Americans if they
happen to be powerless well we put in a
language is to get thoughts across to
communicate if you try to [ __ ] words
so that certain thoughts are impossible
who are difficult to express then you
just made it impossible to get knowledge
and clarity about the state of the world
the same would be true of violence
metaphors are great we can talk about
that use anything as a metaphorical
sense but you really do want to make a
distinction between someone's saying
mean things on Twitter and someone
putting a bullet in your head or nice
between your ribs and say that well
you're not allowed to use words of the
distinguish those if you use the word
violence to refer to physical violence
it has to apply to verbal violence as
well well how are you gonna say even the
thought that I just said that and I just
expressed a namely that there is a big
difference between being murdered and
being insulted or in the case of my own
research that there's been an enormous
decline in the occurrence of physical
violence has there been a decline or
priests or no change in the amount of
insult
well that's an interesting question but
it's it is a separate question and the
point of language is we can pose that
question or any other question that's
the beauty and power of language and the
idea of trying to engineer it in a way
that advances a particular theory or
agenda or political ideology at the
expense of just being able to share our
ideas is my idea because it makes it
hard to the clarity get knowledge get
understanding but it also excludes
people from the discourse in an age in
which we're getting more polarized than
ever
more more and more people not only
disagree with others but think that they
are stupid or and evil since not
everyone can be infallible and
omniscient and correct about everything
there's got to be room for respectful
disagreement trying to engineer language
to make that impossible is a pernicious
idea okay that's pretty
has ever worked where an organization or
someone from the top down imposed a
certain word and then it became part of
the dictionary because people had to use
it there there certainly are changes for
example the the title Miz as opposed to
the former miss missus there was a
campaign in the 1970s it wasn't from in
any organization but that that miss and
missus should be dropped and is they
should be replaced by miss I mean that
was for a particular political agenda
and it it carried the day probably
because it did not it actually increased
the utility of language there are a lot
of times when I I don't know if a woman
is married or not gonna don't care and I
shouldn't be the language wouldn't force
me to decide it kind of gets in the way
of communication together of course with
conveying the attitude that a woman's
marital status is an essential part of
her identity but that is not true of men
and then also been changes in words like
Negro which was very perfectly
acceptable word in the 1960s Martin
Luther King referred to Negroes we have
the United Negro College Fund that was
replaced by black which has been partly
superseded by African American and other
other terms for politically and
emotionally charged concepts like
crippled or people that we would now
call disabled and in between they were
handicapped so there is that kind of
I've called a euphemism treadmill where
one term replaces another again there's
no one who mean the legislates it it is
a grassroots phenomenon the catch is on
there again there is no particular harm
to clarity of communication if you call
someone african-american or you call
them black you're conveying the same
concepts there's a change in attitude
and there so it is possible for
fraternity to change but those are ones
where there was nothing particularly
tendentious and nothing that
particularly impeded communication or
okay thank you so much I appreciate your
time I appreciate them something like 16
hour turnaround from when you received
the request happy anniversary I hope you
do a celebrate well tonight too many
times more than once but the as a place
to celebrate I know this incredibly
touristy but when I go to Toronto I go
up to the top of the CN Tower the best
food in the world and a lot of tourists
there but the view really is spectacular
oh well I don't know if I've been here
an hour than that you know you're not
going to get your way all the time the
other person is not perfect and neither
are you
that's the ground rules that you got to
be a team that lots of people in life
are going to oppose you attack you
undermine you but what when you get home
you've got to have the solidarity of
loyalty and support of your arrest I was
of course working both ways okay thank
you so much that's it have a great day